it was sup guys peace and welcome to
update 2.0 this is going to be it's not
a successor to the update one point
whatever videos update 2.0 because I'm
starting something new what I'm starting
is an inbox kind of thing going on I'm
going to visit my youtube inbox more
than once a week and if I find a few
interesting questions and I like your
questions I will definitely do a video
on them but first of all since this is
an update I just have to congratulate
you guys and thank you guys from reading
my videos so high and favoriting it so
many times the that's the Sony Vegas 8
video the one that I gave away Sony
Vegas
8 Keys 37 favorites I got tons of honors
and I'm finally getting noticed on
YouTube more than 260 subscribers so
keep that up guys that's the first point
all right let's get to the inbox I'm
just going to pull up YouTube right here
and if I like the question enough again
I'll put your link in the description
and you can actually go check it out and
watch and everyone can see your channel
and Co you does take the news to or
something like that
so I'm just going to go to my inbox and
I'm just gonna start rolling down
alright first person to your house phone
asks is this just a free trial it was a
serial code or full version he's talking
about Sony Vegas the Sony Vegas video I
did is a full version so when you get
the key you download the free trial and
it will ask you during the process of
installation of the free trial do you
want to put in a code as a purchase
version and you say yes of course and
then you put in the code I gave you and
there you go
so I'm if you follow the instructions
and then that in that video and you have
a full version full registered version
of Sony 8.0 Sony Vegas 8.0 Pro all right
here's one from NV nine-one-one who s
about the Vegas keys again how do i
unlock the full version I go and enter
the serial number and it says the number
is invalid well there might be a problem
what I would suggest I give you number
one
and then Vicki so if you go to the link
that I gave you in the Sun Sony Vegas
video it will ask you again to download
the free trial and you download the free
trial it'll ask you if you want to use
the keys to make it the full paid
version and use those keys so hopefully
that clarifies everything yeah all right
I've got another message in my inbox
here and it says this is from Iraq and
this is Hannah and her question or his
question was hey I was wondering can you
get more speed dial in Opera web browser
and the answer is yes and that I liked
it enough to do a video tutorial on it
later so stay tuned by the end of this
week hopefully I'll have a tutorial out
on how to add or subtract or customize
change the number of speed dial boxes
you have in Opera in Google Chrome and
in Safari for betta stay tuned for that
so thanks for the question and hopefully
your video will be out go ahead and post
a video response or all I'll post it as
a video response one of my other videos
or something so you guys can get all the
videos connected and everything so
that's that's a good question thanks for
that and I get this question a lot I
have I've gotten it from about six users
some I'm gonna name them all but they
asked what do you use to edit your
videos now that's the most often asked
question and I use Camtasia Studio 6 to
put like annotations and arrows and
stuff and all my videos and the one you
see here I'm using Camtasia Studio 6 and
then people ask me because I've done a
campaign in studio 6 video and a Sony
Vegas video which do you prefer which do
you recommend what should I get well I
like I said if you can follow the
instructions in both of the videos and
you can have both you can compare them
for yourself but what I use more often
just because I'm more familiar with it
is Camtasia Studio 6 it's just a little
more intuitive it's less expensive in
the first place but it's just a little
more intuitive for me so that's what I
use and that's why I use it and another
question I get a lot is how do you make
your videos in HD all I have to say is
I'm going to post that video on how to
do it as a video response so just watch
the video response on how to make your
videos your tutorials your webcam shoes
like me and the highest possible quality
on YouTube so that your viewers can get
the best experience so that's the answer
that question for all of you have asked
that question and finally I get asked a
whole lot since I've brought casted my
skype name so that people can connect
with me how do you call people how do
call businesses and stuff for free
unlimited using Skype so I'm just gonna
show you real quick the number to do
that you can call any business that you
want for free on skype using Google for
one one and a lot of people have done
this already but I'll just tell you
right now add as a Skype contact the
following phone number plus one one
eight hundred four four six four four
one one I'll put it above me I'll put in
the description you guys won't forget it
don't worry but there you go when you
call that number I might as well do the
tutorial on it eventually I guess - you
actually call the number you have to
speak or enter the name of the business
and the location of the business and
boom you're connected whether or not
that business is Skype whether or not
you have Skype credit you can call any
business that you want and it's pretty
much any business trust me if you think
this business hasn't been heard of yet
it's probably in their directory by now
Google has a large database so that is
how you can call any business that you
want in Skype for free and that just
about wraps it up for thank so thank you
for all the questions you've given me
already your links will be in the
description everything is covered here
in the description box so just go ahead
and look over there and now that I
finish put this video on stuff say if
you haven't already subscribed to my
page that is a big part of what I'm
doing here on YouTube I'm trying to get
as much wide audience like as I can to
broadcast my ideas so yeah that's pretty
much it and by the way for the people
who are have been wondering what I'm
listening to right now it's my voice
just in case my mic my mic glitches I
remember in my Camtasia studios in my
camstudio videos my microphone was not
working very well so I actually had to
repeat things if I heard my mic glitch
or anything so I'm just using my ipod
headphones in my laptop here so um that
is basically it so thanks for watching
thanks for subscribing and thanks for
tuning in and listen to what I have to
say so that's it peace